cyber security has become an integral
part of a increasingly digitalized World
from safeguarding sensitive information
to protecting critical infrastructure
the demand for skilled cyber Security
Professionals has skyrocketed but what
about those who are just starting their
journey in this feat two entry-level
cyber security jobs actually exist cyber
security is not merely a buzzword it's a
pressing concern that affects
governments corporations and individuals
alike with the rise of sophisticated
cyber threats organizations are actively
seeking talented individuals to join
their ranks and fortified their defenses
are there opportunities available for
fresh faces with a passion for cyber
security the answer is a resounding yes
entry-level cyber security jobs are
indeed a reality offering a pathway for
aspiring professionals to enter this
exciting field with the growing
recognition of the importance of cyber
security organizations have realized the
need to invest in talented individuals
from the ground up
these entry-level positions serve as
stepping stones providing invaluable
hands-on experience and an opportunity
to develop foundational skills in
various aspects of cyber security from
security analysts to network security
technicians to penetration testers and
Security Consultants the entry-level
roles within cyber security are as
diverse as the threats they aim to
combat so let's take a look at some of
the entry-level jobs present in cyber
security but before that if you enjoy
watching these videos and find them
attractive then subscribe to our YouTube
channel because we bring the best videos
for you Dave also press the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from Simply if
you want to master the field of cyber
security then simply learns postgraduate
program in cyber security in
collaboration with MIT is clearly the
right choice for you this postgraduate
program in cyber security is designed to
equip you with the skills required to
become an expert in the rapidly growing
field of cyber security the cyber
security program aims to help you stay
ahead of the latest cyber security
Trends key features of this program
simply learns postgraduate certificate
master classes from MIT faculty
featuring modules from MIT SCC and EC
Council access to ceh Kit 25 plus
Hands-On projects and many this cyber
security program begins with
introductory level skills and then
progresses to advance cybers security
Technologies this program covers all the
essential skills you will need to become
an expert in the field of cyber security
cyber security is one of the top
concerns of businesses today in any
industry from securing data to
anticipating cyber attacks and placing
enterprise-wide safeguards to prevent
them employers worldwide are
increasingly looking for qualified cyber
Security Professionals to join them so
what are you waiting for find the course
link mentioned in the description box
below and enroll today a lot of
individuals have attained high salaries
and better career opportunities through
this postgraduate program so let's take
a minute to hear it out hi I'm Philip
I'm 61 years old and last year I upscale
was simply learns postgraduate program
at cyber security after working 30 years
in the IIT sector and various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course course I
must say was packed with practical
examples it was led by highly skilled
certified instructors I worked with many
companies before the security analysts
and the architect on a contract basis
but I needed some stability which I got
with the job I just started with Infosys
as a cyber security consultant happened
after I took the course but first and
foremost I've been a learner be a
learner first let's start this video
with a small introduction to what
entry-level jobs in cyber security are
entry-level jobs refers to the rules
that require little to no professional
experience in the field
these positions are designed to provide
individuals with an opportunity to learn
and grow while gaining valuable
practical skills now that we understand
the concept of entry-level jobs let's
take a look at some common positions
available to beginners in the field of
cyber security
remember the availability in these roles
may vary depending on your location and
the job market
the first job rule is of a security
analyst security analysts play a vital
role in monitoring and analyzing
security threats they assist in incident
response vulnerability assessments and
security system administration
this role often involves working with
senior analysts and learning from their
expertise salaries May differ for every
job role but according to Glassdoor the
average salary of a security analysts
goes up to 78 000 in the United States
in India the same security analyst can
earn up to 580 000 rupees per annum you
can expect a little lower than that or
somewhat the same but still it is a
handsome salary to start your career the
second job rule is of Security operation
Center analyst or sock analyst sock
analysts work in a 24 7 security
operations center monitoring and
responding to security incidents they
analyze security alerts investigate
potential threats and ensure the
organization's system are secure
this position provides valuable hands-on
experience in threat detection and
incident response a stock analyst in the
United States earn around 87 000
annually and the same stock analyst in
India earns around 4 lakh 80 000 rupees
per annum the last job role is that of a
junior penetration tester penetration
testers also known as ethical hackles
identify vulnerabilities in an
organization's systems and networks
Junior penetration testers work
alongside experienced professionals
assisting with vulnerability assessments
conducting security tests and analyzing
results
a junior penetration tester in the
United States earns around 80 000
annually and the same tester in India
earns around 4 lakh nine thousand rupees
per year
while these postings are entry level
it's important to note that specific
skills and qualifications can give you
an edge when applying for these jobs so
some of these skills that employees
often look for includes foundational
knowledge a basic understanding of
networking operating systems and
security fundamentals is crucial
familiarity with programming languages
like python or Powershell can be
beneficial certifications entry level
certifications such as com tis Security
Plus certified information system
security professional or certified
ethical hacker can demonstrate your
commitment and knowledge in the field
the postgraduate program in cyber
security will definitely help you crack
these tests the third one is practical
experience while experience may not be
mandatory practical projects internships
or participation in cyber security
competitions can set you apart from
other candidates now that we know what
entry level cyber security jobs are and
the skills required so let's discuss
some tips to help you land your dream
job in the field
build a strong Foundation focus on
building a solid understanding of code
cyber security Concepts and Technologies
take online courses attend webinars and
engage with the cyber security community
correct with Professionals in Industry
through events forums and social media
platforms networking can open many dose
to potential job opportunities and
mentorship
creating a portfolio showcase your
skills by developing personal projects
or contributing to open source
initiatives a portfolio can demonstrate
your practical abilities and dedication
it's important to note that the specific
job titles and requirements may vary
depending on the organization and its
needs however entry level jobs in cyber
security provide valuable opportunities
for individuals to gain experience
develop skills and grow within the field
so here's everything you need to know
about entry level positions available in
the field of cyber security so with that
we have come to the end of this video if
you still feel that we have missed out
on some Vital Information then please
feel free to drop your queries or
suggestions in the comments below and a
team of experts will definitely guide
you so thank you so much for being here
guys we'll see you next time until then
stay safe and keep learning with simply
learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign